Nobody can cause mental pain to you. It is you in reaction to something that happens around you.
It is time you take away the nonsense that's happening within you. Once your intelligence is against you
there is no force on the planet or anywhere which can save you. Right now people's idea of success is they're doing better than their neighbor.
No.
Your idea of success should be that you are a full-fledged life.
In one word your most important core value what would you say it is...
What's up belief nation. New format today. We are heading to go interview
Sadhguru. He is a
indian mystic yogi on a mission that changed the world
A top-10 was the first video i did on him and
before that I had never heard of him. Bunch of my audience asked for him and I said "okay, let's look into this guy"
and he had a really interesting message so we made the video.
It exploded got two and a half million views and
he was in Toronto last night doing his mystic eye event that Nina and I attended, 6000 people filling the
convention centre and
he gave us some time this morning.
Early sunday morning
minus 5 degrees outside, he wants to do an outdoor interview so we're gonna go meet him downtown and
see
what kind of knowledge he can give us.
Welcome everybody. Special youtube interview. I'm very honored and blessed to be here with the legendary Sadhguru thank you so much for spending
time here. He has an event happening in Toronto. It was an amazing event last night, 6000 people showed up and he's got to run
to another city, more adventures but made a few minutes for us this morning. I had a whole bunch of questions ready for you
kind of going in, but after experiencing your event I thought I'd maybe quickly lead off with something a little more personal for me
because it was,
you know, mind shifting kind of being at that event last night.
You did this activity
where to get us awake and energize. You had us close our eyes and you count to three and then we had to yell
lose our inhibitions and and let it all out and that
idea of kind of losing control losing inhabitions for me personally has actually been a
challenge and I was hoping to get your perspective. I have
never done drugs because I don't want to lose control I fight roller coasters because I don't like losing control the body
Am I supposed to believe all this?
I'm excited for your perspective. I don't know why it's a..
it came up because last night I did my best but it's always been a
challenge or a struggle for me and I'm just curious to get your perspective.
Nature has imposed
substantial amount of
restrictions on life.
You can't just zoom out into the space.
There is enough restrictions.
You don't have to invent your own restrictions on top of it.
So if you invent your own restrictions
slowly over a period of time you become a constipated life.
That means
life won't happen easy. It happens in small
happenings. So being in a state of abandoned, not out of control,
being in a state of abandoned means
all the stuffs that you have put on yourself you pulled it off.
Native stops are still there for your safety and your well-being
but, why are you imposing stops?
There's enough, gravity is holding you down that's bad enough.
Now you want to hold yourself down. Why? Because fear.
What is the fear about? The fear is always about
"If I do this I may suffer". So that is the fundamental of my work:
to bring you to your place where there's no fear of suffering,
because
there're only two kinds of sufferings that you go through, physical suffering and mental suffering. When we say physical suffering
there is pain in the body.
Unfortunately the truth is if there was no pain in the body
most human beings would have destroyed themselves
mutilated themselves.
See already you have done, see wherever there is no pain you chopped it off right. If there's no pain in your nose i'm sure
in the name of fashion you would've cut it into ribbons.
If there's no pain in the body at all,
maybe you would have pulled out your intestines and walked in the street, you look jessie.
Looks grotesque
but believe me if there was no pain people would have just destroyed themselves cut them into bits.
Right now there is pain that is what is keeping them in one piece.
So physical pain is there
but the fear of suffering is not just about pain. The fear of suffering is self-inflicted.
Nobody can cause mental pain to you. It is you in reaction to something that happens around you
that you cause pain to yourself.
If you
have half your brain removed
then you would see you would be quite peaceful.
Right now people are going through stress, anxiety, depression,
misery, all kinds of things.
You can give it any number of exotic names that you want, but essentially
their intelligence has turned against them. That's all it is. Once your intelligence is against you
there is no force on the planet or anywhere which can save you.
So the fundamental thing is
to bring this: that all the faculties that we have should work for our well-being.
Right now our own body our own mind our own emotions are working against us.
This one thing has to be fixed, which is the machine.
And I love it and and bring it to
entrepreneurs, this good core my audience, people want to start their own business
the spiritual side of
bringing that into a company, what advice would you have for somebody who's starting their own company and how to do it in a in
a well-being way?
See, the nature of activity doesn't really matter whether you're doing business or sport or music or art.
It doesn't matter what you're doing. The important thing is you must be a full-fledged life.
So if you are not a full-fledged life in the sense
if your body, if your mind, if your emotions, your intelligence
do not cooperate with you, what kind of enterprise are you going to do?
Just survival business. If you just make a few bucks to survive, that's it. That's not what enterprise means.
Enterprise means constantly to step into new terrain. That's what it means.
If you want to step into new terrain,
tell me if fear is a very supportive emotion that you can carry with you.
No. You will always look for the familiar. When there is fear you always look for the familiar. When you look
for the familiar there is no enterprise.
Maybe there is some retail business.
The idea that you talked about last night was if you get too entangled or trapped in something
versus being involved in something and having a little bit of space to breathe and the freedom in that. Could you maybe explain on that?
People are always thinking that
something else or somebody else is restricting their freedom
but one's freedom is lost simply because they are tangled up with their own body and their own mind.
These are two dimensions of you, two faculties.
Unless your body and your mind
is fully in your hands if they are continuously working for you never against you
only then you can live a successful life.
People have approached in a well being
either with belief systems or philosophies or ideologies or some wacky ideas of their own.
It's time to approach your inner well-being in a scientific manner as the science and technology to create external well-being.
There is a whole science and technology to create inner well-being
That is what we call as calling as inner engineering, technologies for well-being.
It is time that you approach your inner well-being also in a
scientific systematic way and employ technologies to create this well-being.
Everything else you using technology, you understand that technology can facilitate everything on the outside.
Why don't you understand that
the best piece of technology on this planet is this human mechanism.
Unless you approach it properly it will not live.
Living here is half a human being is not good enough.
Right now people's idea of success is they are doing better than their neighbor
No.
Your idea of success should be that you are a full-fledged life because this is not my idea this is not my philosophy
this is the longing of every life every worm, insect, bird, tree, animal and also a human being.
We're always striving to become a full-fledged
life
but, we know what is a full fledge one,
we know what is a full-fledged insect, we know what is a full-fledged apple tree,
but, we don't know what's a full-fledged human being. That's where the problem is.
What do you recommend as as habits for people to incorporate on a daily basis to feel that way?
Here everybody is looking for tidbits of life.
"Give me three points with which i will make my life" "One mantra with which everything will be solved"
That's not how life is. It's a comprehensive process.
The simple way to look at it is like this:
today you know because of medical sciences that your entire body in a way is a chemical soup.
The question is only: is it a great soup or a lousy soup?
So if it's a great soup,
then it tastes wonderful for you and tastes wonderful for everybody around you. If it's a lousy soup
then you have to manage with presentation.
When the chef is bad, you know, he decorates it. These days food comes with flowers on it?
Never ever outside situations will happen hundred percent your way
but what happens within you, if it's happening hundred percent your way, you will be in the best possible state always.
You will keep yourself in the best possible way. "Are you as good as somebody?" That's not the point.
"Are you full-fledged?" That is the point.
You're not expecting the dog to fly though he's wearing a superman suit
Though he's wearing a superman suit you're not expecting him to fly
But you want him to be a full-fledged dog.
Right.
You want the bird to be a full-fledged bird.
You want a human being to be a full-fledged human being.
So being in a state of abandoned does not mean you abandon your life, you abandon all your
stops, breaks.
You driving all the time it breaks on is a silly way to drive because
fear is ruling you not your sense.
If you especially, if you're an entrepreneur
if you call yourself an entrepreneur,
you're willingly stepping into
unknown territory. That's what it means.
With brakes on you can't drive like that.
And what's what's the fear of?
Suffering?
Hmm.
In some way, fear of failure, fear of this, you can call it many names,
essentially you fear that you will suffer if things don't happen the way you think they should happen, isn't it?
Outside things
if you look long enough like me
you know outside things will never happen the way you want it.
That happened to some extent but what's within you must happen the way you want it.
You told the story of a man who had wings but never use them to fly and just
reproduce and had a life and isn't it a tragedy that he never used his wings to fly?
Do you feel like most of us are walking through life with wings and we never use them to fly?
Unfortunately yes. A whole lot of people too many people.
It's time
that human potential is unleashed
because we are the first generation on the planet for whom our survival is organized better than ever before. Ever before.
So this is the time to unlock our potential
to lose those all kinds of inhibitions and fears that we had. There was a time
if as much as cloud gathered and lightning and thunder happened, we thought that God was angry with us. Okay?
All those things are gone. It is time you take away the nonsense that's happening within you and
the entire process the science of inner engineering is just this: how to work at it in a scientific manner,
not with philosophy. I can tell you a thousand times "Give up your fear". It's not going to go but if your chemical soup is blissful,
there's not even an
idea of fear in your mind.
It reminds me of your concept of the movies. You play the movies in your mind. You can choose a drama, you can choose a
horror story or you can choose a positive movie and
not get stuck in the same movie forever. You can turn it off and start a new one.
Yeah, but for that you should know where the switches are.
— Right.
You are like a supercomputer
but you haven't found a keyboard yet.
Time to find the keyboard. That's my work: to give people the keyboard for their supercomputer.
I love it.
For people who want who maybe this is the first exposure to hearing your message
they want to learn more, what what's the next best step?
There is a simple online
possibility
seven-day program which they can do and after that there is a day and a half event
which always happens
personally with me
where they get, you know, introduced
into a very powerful practice
which changes the basic chemistry of who you are.
In four to six weeks, you can find a significant difference in the very way you function.
And today millions of people across the planet have taken this.
Number it was estimating, some media people in india were estimating, till now we've touched somewhere near half a billion people and
that is largely
by people taking it upon themselves.
If you even look on the net you will see
most of the videos and material is transmitted by people not by the foundation.
People are doing it because they found it so
super beneficial in their life, it's transformed their life, they want it to happen to their friends and their family and that's how
the entire process has grown.
Well, I know, I know you have a plane to catch. I really appreciate your time this morning.
Thank you.
Final question in one word your most important core value what would you say it is?
ーClarity.
Clarity. I like it.
If you don't see things the way they are, whatever you do is going to be a mess.
I like it. Thank you for the time today. I appreciate it.
— Thank you.
My hope is that for
entrepreneurs watching just to add a different side just to
learn a little bit more both the spiritual side
and just give people a different flavor.
So all the follow-up questions were were mostly for the audience and for you guys right to be able to
learn a little bit about what I learned last night and hopefully hear it in his own words, not mine.
The first question I asked was about me being
not having abandon or not be able to, you know, like fighting rollercoasters and not doing drugs and
let loose so I don't know. What am I afraid of? What's the suffering i'm afraid of?
I don't know Ihaven't figured that i got some thinking to do.
I gotta meditate on that. Anyway, I appreciate the time and the answers and hopefully you guys learned something from that, too and
hope it's a new perspective. Maybe there's something that you'd take away and
want to pull on that thread a little bit more. I think that's the key part if you get just a hint of an idea
that this might be worth exploring.
That's all you need. You just need the seed
that could lead to a life-changing moment. It doesn't all have to make sense but a little piece a little tiny nugget that
you want to digest,
then just think about it. It kind of made sense to you you want to explore it.
Think about it. Spend some time on it and
who knows? Maybe your life changes.
The most important word ever.
If you had to think of one word that's most important, to you or that sums you apple that would be collect a little beacon
Hey believe nation. If you want to know what the most important one word is for Tony Robbins, Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey, Will.i.am and Howard Schultz, I have a very special secret video for you check the description for details.